Hey youtubers it's Charlie and the CW just
confirmed Katana for Arrow Season 3 and the
character who would be playing her husband.
They're going to be like the prequel version
of Team Arrow in the Hong Kong Flashbacks.
So this video is going to be a breakdown of
the Katana character and a look at what's
going to be happening in the flashbacks.
Hello to any new people just finding me for
the first time, I do Arrow and Flash videos
every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And yes I will be doing videos for all the
new DC and Marvel shows when they get here.
Hong Kong Arrow Cave time, seriously though.
The new flashbacks will be all about Oliver
learning to take what he learned on the island
and apply it to an Urban area.
It's the in-between training he gets before
he came back to Starling in the pilot.
I know in the pilot he had full on super beard
and it looked like he'd been stranded for
months, but the way they tease his missing
years make it seem like he left and went back
to the island more than once during that period.
He didn't spend all 5 years on the island.
So Devin Aoki will be Katana, you probably
remember her best from Sin City or Dead or
Alive, Katana's husband is named Maseo Yamashiro,
he'll be played by Karl Yune.
He was in Real Steel.
Katana is a big comic book character, Yamashiro
is her husband in the comics, but he's a much
smaller character.
He was resurrected as a Black Lantern during
Blackest Night though.
So let's start with Katana first, she actually
just got a brand new comic book that launched
the same time they launched the Vibe comic
book.
And he's a character on the Flash show, so
it's not a coincidence that they decided to
use her character.
Katana has also appeared in the Birds of Prey
comics and the Arrow producers have said we're
getting more Birds of Prey stories in Season
3.
Felicity being the Oracle character in that
situation.
Her real name is Tsatsu and she was always
very good at martial arts even as a child.
Growing up she had two suitors, her future
husband Maseo and his brother Takeo.
Two brothers in love with the same woman,
what could possibly go wrong?
Her parents were murdered and she had twin
girls, Yuki and Reiko.
The other brother Takeo came into possession
of a mystical blade called Soultaker and came
to kill his brother, in the process of that
Maseo and Katana's twin daughters died and
she killed Tsatsu, the brother with Soultaker.
Her husband's spirit ended up being trapped
in the blade and she took on the Katana persona
after training with a master.
She's mostly been featured as part of the
Outsiders in that comic, but she's also been
part of the Birds of Prey and Suicide Squad
teams.
She also had a storyline that crossed over
with the Geo Force and Terra characters in
Markovia.
Remember in Arrow Season 2, someone from Markovia
tried to buy Merlin's prototype earthshaker
device.
That wasn't an early sign they would end up
using Katana, but it's just an example of
how they tie plot points together across seasons.
Her character also crossed over with Lady
Shiva several times, she isn't a villain,
she's more of an antagonist.
I know a lot of you really wanted Lady Shiva
to come on the show, and she still can.
She's another League of Assassin's character
that is a good foil for Katana.
They could give the Lady Shiva persona to
a different character like they did with Ravager
and Isobel Rochev.
Based on the way Arrow teases big comic book
character reveals, I'm guessing that Katana
won't be Katana in the Hong Kong flashbacks.
She'll be featured in present day too, there's
no way you cast a character that big and don't
let them be a badass in present day.
And because her husband is alive in the Hong
Kong flashbacks, she probably won't have Soultaker
yet either.
I don't think Arrow will go supernatural yet,
they'll probably just name the blade that.
It's not going to turn into an episode of
Buffy the Vampire Slayer or anything.
It would be funny if the blade spoke with
Misha Collins or Jared Padalecki's voice.
It would be nice to know their souls were
being used to fight crime and kill bad guys
in the dc universe.
So Katana won't be full on Katana when we
meet her for the first time, she and her husband
Maseo will be Oliver's Hong Kong handlers.
They'll work for Amanda Waller and train Oliver
as he begins his business relationship with
ARGUS.
Maseo is going to be like a cross between
Diggle and Yao Fei.
He'll be like his friend but also continue
the training Yao Fei gave him on the island.
Katana will also be friends with Oliver.
The three of them will become like the proto
version of Team Arrow.
All superheroes either choose to build a team
around themselves or work alone.
Batman is a character that largely works alone
even though several version of Robin have
come and gone.
Oliver is a team player.
The Hong Kong flashbacks will show us why
that is and why he thought bringing Felicity
and Diggle in was so important in season 1.
I'm really excited, if you haven't seen.
Stephen Amell has been posting a ton of workout
videos to his facebook page.
He's doing all this parkour free running obstacle
stuff.
The area where he's working out is laid out
like a city.
So expect him to be parkouring the shit out
of Hong Kong.
They are showing off footage from Season 3
at Comic Con so I'm wondering if it will be
something from the flashbacks so they can
show off the new characters.
I have a feeling they'll tease some details
about the new Arrow Cave if they don't show
footage of it.
It's basically going to be in that place Felicity
and Diggle found Oliver hiding after Moira's
funeral.
It was a backup location he created in case
the original arrowcave under the foundry was
compromised.
And at the end of season 2 they mirakuru soldiers
trashed the place.
I've already done a blue beetle video, he's
the big teased superhero character.
They used some fake names in the casting,
but the name they used for him was the name
of the Golden Age Blue Beetle.
They used false names for Katana and Maseo,
so I'm guessing we're going to get the Ted
Kord version of the character.
I know Steven McQueen said the Nightwing rumors
were not true, but Nightwing was a huge part
of The Outsiders just like Katana, so she
does get us one step closer to seeing Nightwing
on the show.
In the new 52 Universe, Katana joined the
Suicide Squad in exchange for Amanda Waller's
help tracking down her husband Maseo's killers,
so when we see Katana in present day Arrow,
when she's got the sword.
It's possible they could use some aspects
of that storyline as a way to bring her back
into Oliver's life.
In the new solo Katana comic when she's tracking
down her husband's killers, she finds out
that they're connected to Green Arrow's Origins
and the Outsiders.
Remember how Amanda Waller turned out to be
the one behind Edward Fyers on the island?
What if they tie her husband's murder and
the Outsiders to that same organization.
Waller's operation in Hong Kong.
She isn't a villain, but she has been a justice
league antagonist in the past.
Usually on the show they do a good job of
setting up new characters at the beginning
of the season, establishing relationships
around Oliver, tearing them down, then connecting
them to a much bigger plot at the end.
So you leave the season feeling like everyone
in the flashbacks and in the present is tied
together by a single villain.
They've teased some smaller villains, but
I'm wondering if Amanda Waller is going to
become the villain of season 3.
That would be a twist.
Let me know in the comments what you think
of the Katana character coming on Arrow.
I can't wait to see her in a birds of prey
episode with Felicity and Huntress.
So Stephen Amell is doing a ton of stuff at
Comic Con this month.
I'll be doing all kinds of bonus videos for
that and for Arrow and the Flash in general
so subscribe to get everything and be sure
to check out my Ronan the accuser video I
posted yesterday.
You can click here to get it and click here
to learn more about Blue Beetle and the other
new Arrow characters.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!